if you're if you're insecure about being
able to own your own money do you own it
and can you actually use it without
asking somebody's permission then uh the
solution Is Not Gold it's not silver
coins it's not stacks of cash it's not
money in a bank in the U.S it's
certainly not money in a bank in Lebanon
Argentina anywhere in Africa those Banks
won't let you they won't let you take
your money out of the bank look at
Nigeria 42 dollars a day that's how much
you can take out of the bank they're
keeping your money
so the one network that you have that
gives you a decent chance of owning your
own money and then being able to spend
it the way you want
is Bitcoin